all right Andrew Cortina welcome to the
podcast thanks for having me how's it
going man
pretty good cool so you are the founder
or co-founder of both venmo and fin but
you're also blogger yeah and I wanted to
talk to you about a couple of your
essays specifically around work human
dignity there's one called the beautiful
struggle a beautiful game and you end it
with as we give more and more work to
software machines I think it's worth
asking why we've historically regarded
work as fundamental to human dignity and
whether or not it's still useful to do
so so I found this interesting because
you wrote this after selling venmo
mmm-hmm and then you went and started
another company I assume like you could
have taken some time off it not worked
why do you go back to work yeah I think
it's I think it's very difficult to
change your own idea of dignity and I
don't necessarily even think it's
something that you come up with yourself
like I've thought a lot about this and
when I was younger I kind of thought I
had an idea of like okay look what is
the good you know what does it mean to
like be a good person and just either
that was some like objective truth or it
was like something I had like come up
with myself and I think the older I've
gotten and the more fortunate I've been
in life the more I kind of recognize
that a lot of things that I have are not
measure things like I have accomplished
myself but things I've received from
like teachers or like reading great
books from the past 2,000 years of
Western civilization or the culture that
I grew up in the country that I grew up
in there's like all these things that
you know you think you can take credit
for like a work ethic right like that
seems like one of the most you know free
will determined
yeah a strong work ethic but you
probably learned that from some role
model and I know that so anyway to get
back to that question I think I've sort
of come to think more and more about
okay like where does my own conception
of dignity come from why does that why
would that involve like working and like
making things or doing things for other
people and I feel like a little bit less
ownership of it and I guess where I was
going with that as I was like okay why
would a culture connect dignity with the
idea of work and it's I just think it's
been a useful thing to do if you live in
a very uncertain world where there's
things like you know a horde of locusts
can take out the crops for the year and
then there's famine right like you want
to incentivize people to be productive
and create a surplus so you can kind of
like endure those natural catastrophes
and for me I like growing up in the
United States I think there's there's a
lot of connection between like work and
entrepreneurship and dignity and kind of
like doing service for others in your
country kind of gets back to this like
Protestant work ethic stuff and even
though I think I can recognize like all
these sort of like cultural influences
on my own conception of Bigley it's
really hard to I think convince yourself
of something otherwise because you know
it's all a ruse and like even I know on
the one hand you could say it should
make it easier to like just change your
mind about something yeah but like if
it's if it's been inside of you for so
long it can just feel like I don't know
I got like I just I don't want to go
like sit around and do heroin all day
like oh that would be like really fun
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with that but if it would be very tough
for me to like not feel bad about that
even though I don't think it's a bad
thing for somebody to do and I think
it's like just as dignified as working
on you know
an important problem but they don't know
this stuff gets in green pretty deeply
and I think it's hard to change for
somebody especially once they're older
like maybe it can change across
generations mmm I think it takes time
well you did describe I forget I think
it was in that maybe it wasn't an essay
before these kind of like flow state
moments you've had outside of work you
know you were talking about moving this
like bench to the house and I though
that was great that was like a serious
contraption is so fun yeah yeah and like
that's a thing I mean I think that's
actually maybe even more of a default
mode in the Bay Area where you see
people like entering in this state of
like vaguely working and then they just
like do projects right and but yet did
that compel you like maybe working with
your hands and like jumping from one of
those one to the next because I when I'm
going through these essays I'm like are
these just thought experiments or do you
just take a month or two and like
actually become a Buddhist and see what
happens - you know I've never like
there's I have a love-hate relationship
never like done it myself but it's very
much like my American point of view
where it's like I had this thought once
like you know Buddhists are not gonna
get us off this planet when the Sun
burns out like it's a very from my sort
of you know 50,000 foot view of it it
seems like a very like internal focused
life is struggling how do I cope with
this and like pacify my you know
struggle with the futility of existence
and all the pain and suffering that
exists in life but I don't see a lot in
that sort of philosophy that would
motivate a civilization to like do large
projects that help lots of people and I
think that's one of the cool things
about American culture is like I do see
that and like that's kind of what I like
about the idea of like dignified work is
that
you know it is a motive to inspire the
people who have been a little bit more
fortunate to do things that might help
people that are less fortunate I think
that's cool but it sort of presupposes
this world where that was necessary and
as that becomes less necessary and
there's more abundance then we're less a
sort of resource constraint that
connection between dignity and like
doing useful work
maybe becomes dangerous and like if you
know maybe not everyone has to be
productive maybe not everyone has the
opportunity to be productive and then
are those people sort of like locked out
I've ever have any a dignified life just
because we had this useful mechanism for
motivating people in the past which is a
weird situation I might know something I
think about a lot so then do you do you
not buy the argument that humans are
very very good at creating jobs when we
when we were talking last week I was
talking to you about people playing
truck driving simulator on Twitch and
then making money by having fans don't
hate to their truck driving simulator
talents you don't think that's realistic
I think humans are very good at creating
jobs that is I think that's like an
attention economy thing right like
watching other people drive trucks and
my guess is they would follow a
power-law or like a vast majority of
people would watch a few people doing it
I think most things follow a power-law
and so with respect to like I don't know
like like you arguments of people make
or when we get to the point where nobody
has to work anymore everyone will just
do art I'm not sure like there it
depends on why you're doing art one of
the things I like about like creating
things as sharing them with other people
mm-hmm and it's pretty depressing when
you're like putting like months of work
into something and you put it out there
and then nobody enjoys it right
so I'm not sure that's the answer to
like what will people do when they don't
have to like do manual labor anymore but
I don't know I think we're probably a
long way from the point where nobody has
to work anymore
yeah but we should be thinking about it
we should be thinking about it that way
that was how you ended the other essay
when you said like what would be the
last human job gratitude and yet it
still resonates with you yeah I'd like I
still like that one it's always good
when you look back onto the wrote a long
time ago and you still like it yes it
doesn't happen that often yeah yeah all
right
so I'm I'm curious about this the this
failure mode that you're talking about
and the beautiful struggle what I'll
read the posts and then you can look at
you can describe it you might argue that
we've already that we're already in a
sort of failure mode where our ability
to assign dignity to arbitrary work and
motivate people to work [ __ ] jobs is
more efficient than our ability to
allocate labor towards industry that
would have greater social benefit like
education health care food etc if we're
already in this failure mode it's kind
of the worst of all worlds because not
only are we assigning meeting to work
that doesn't need to be done but also we
could be redeploying the labor towards
efforts that are actually important
today do you think we're there yeah I
mean I think about this a lot when I go
to a supermarket and I guess I know when
you I got into the habit of like going
just like you know uh like a bodega in
New York for a long time if I needed to
space or something and I remember I had
this experience where it was the first
time in years I got into like a big
supermarket to get toothpaste and there
was like a whole [ __ ] aisle of
toothpaste and I just was like and I was
like vividly remember I was like reading
about this and like trying to like make
this into a thing I haven't done yet but
I'll probably still use it it was like I
walked into this supermarket and like I
had
made several attempts to get I needed a
toothbrush okay and it made several
attempts to like get toothbrushes we're
like I saw some place on Valencia Street
but I saw some people like in there I
was like I can't see mirror them right
now like I mean I was like brushing my
teeth with my finger face for like a
couple days and then there was like this
Saturday I was like alright I'm gonna do
it I'm going to get my toothbrush today
and I walked into this Safeway and Bruce
Springsteen's everybody has a hungry
heart was on the radio and I went and I
asked him was like where is the tooth
brush aisle and this is like this
massive store and I had to like navigate
there and I get to the aisle it's just
like a wall of toothbrushes and I wanted
like just a regular you know yeah cheap
$1.00 toothbrush I know I was standing
there for like five minutes like trying
to find a cheap shitty too and then I
just was like have a like I'm never
gonna get this five minutes back like
this is the worst possible thing ever
and just like look at all the garbage in
front of me right like and think about
all like the time and like the people
that thought about you know this
toothbrush versus that toothbrush and
all the effort that went into like that
and marketing that stuff and you know
somebody then went and stocked all this
stuff and like made a decision that this
is what should be on the Shelf from this
store and this is how many toothbrushes
they have and there was just like okay
this is like so wasteful yeah like they
just wasted like five minutes of my time
which I'm pissed off about
but like the entire sort of line of
production and marketing and
distribution that went into like making
that moment happen and just a total
waste and it's just like if you if you
think about the things that you actually
need to survive and the things that you
let you value kind of at the end of the
day or like when you're reflecting on
things right it's such a small piece of
Commerce that's happening right now and
there's just so much garbage put out
there because it's like easy to sell
I think yeah well I think there's it's
both easy to sell and then people like
games right so you're entering into this
company and this market where you're
like I can I can do better than that guy
yeah without stepping back in thinking
do we really need rest you know
toothbrush with like a thousand bristles
instead nine hundred yeah I mean this is
the kind of my thought about the
singularity is that it already happened
and money is the algorithm that is
already controlling all the people and
telling them what to do the machines
have already taken over I think uh
literally from the beginning of money
we're gonna think yeah I thought that's
so interesting I thought it was going it
was coming through our phones and
because we're getting used to
intermediating between these like pretty
bad devices it's going to be so easy for
us to just have the full integration
happen as soon as you're interacting
with like AI podcast guests a itíd uses
the Chinese AI newscaster know it was on
hacker news the other day it was great I
mean it's like completely digital
newscaster but that's an interesting
thought yeah does anyone money and
dopamine because that's the one that
you're fun access to is that like an
internal secret venmo slogan money and
different me know money is the API for
humans no actually we wanted to kind of
like humanize the money and make it less
about the dollars and cents it more
that's why the the note is like such a
focal point of M I was like what is the
thing that you're doing what is the
moment that you're sharing with somebody
else yeah I get you thinking about that
and not about the money and the money is
just hopefully in the background hmm so
if this world like the commercial world
is overwhelming to you or just wonder
whatever too much
do you practice some kind of Stoicism
you have nothing in your apartment
what does it look like no I mean I have
so my girlfriend has a bed I would have
it just a mattress on the floor but then
I'll have like like stuff that I use
like I have a couple of good knives for
like cutting vegetables right and like
cutting board or like good pots and pans
but then I don't have like tons of other
[ __ ] and like I'll try it like if I if
I'm not wearing clothes I'll try to get
rid of them so I know on the one hand I
don't have tons of stuff but then like
for the stuff that I know I'm gonna use
a lot I like it to be something good
mm-hmm I don't really have a no I
remember this I had this professor in
college this guy John Rick Eddie and he
was I was studying Shakespeare in London
and he was like the professor from my
school that was also like abroad and
like I was studying abroad he was
teaching abroad and so he would like do
stuff with us and he had this over for
Thanksgiving dinner and he would always
be taking us to plays and stuff and I
remember one time he told me that uh he
was just we were like you know drinking
a glass of wine or something and he was
like you know when I when I die I want
them to very um my gravestone he always
lived beyond his means I just I really
respect that sentiment so like I don't
know I don't know having tons of stuff
but I also have no problem with that
kind of like extravagance in like form
of expression yeah I mean if that
satisfies you and can keep you going
year after year
yeah I don't I don't know I don't see it
happened very often but yeah I don't
think it but I know for those people I
like it that was more like the kind of
like host vibe him you know yeah he had
it wasn't like he was necessarily buying
like tons of objects it was like
spending money to like entertain or
something right
well that more falls in lines like
spend money on experiences in but which
is again become contentious of like
these color factory type things where
we've like oh my yeah bend money on
artificial manufactured experience yeah
for vanity yeah
I mean it's also just depressingly
commercial or just like travel I don't
know like I was in I went to Cambodia I
think a couple years ago you think
you're in Cambodia I think was someplace
late but that's all Asia yeah the market
you know the street market there looked
exactly like the street market in Mexico
City and was just like this the entire
time here there was like you in this
relationship to everyone else there as
the tourist and everything was designed
to like extract money from you either in
the form of like goods or experiences
and like tours and stuff and just to
this point our like so much rather go
like explore YouTube then like be
subjected to that kind of like
commercial tourism machine
well average input average output yeah
you know you can I'm sure I've never
been to Cambodia but I'm sure if you go
off the beaten path you can have that
experience and you can have that
experience if you just you know talk to
someone instead of trying buy t-shirts
right yeah but it's very thing that it's
hard to actually talk to someone there
an escape that you know you as tourists
construct my the thing that's changed
for me in the past I don't know five
years I've gotten really into bike
touring oh that's cool bike touring is
cool
first of all because anyone can do it
it's not hard like you can just start
with like 10 miles a day stay in hotels
but second is that it makes you
interesting to everyone around the world
which I found to be super cool yeah
that's really cool and you're the least
interesting in the places where you like
in basically Europe right like in like
the most traditional touristy places so
really I don't really like the first of
all there's infrastructure to explore
all that stuff but it's also like I
don't even need to go there now instead
I can go to Vietnam and ride bikes
around there that's cool which point
people people love you yeah yeah yeah so
I mean I could see a world yeah I spent
like five months in a road bike touring
I didn't want to do it forever yeah but
that was that point where I was like oh
I am pulled back to work whether that's
like a constant work for this you know
this company or this like long-term
project I have no idea but like I want
to do something but yeah why do
something you know like Wyatt like is
that natural or is that just because you
know of all the things that you've read
right like why do we want to do
something yeah I don't know it's a I I
was able to scratch the itch of like
physical exertion day after day well
bike touring after a while I stopped
doing you know a new city every night
because he spent so much time thinking
about logistics which is really boring
and tiring but even so I think I just
came to the conclusion that like the
person that I wanted to be was not an
adventure blogger yeah yeah but if
that's what you want to do it's super
cool yeah but yeah I mean I couldn't
come to an answer of why do something
like I guess without infinite money and
it's like okay I need to do something
yeah yeah well in the future yeah yeah I
mean it's definitely a question mark do
you do you have visions of like you know
assuming you don't work on friends
forever your post fin life probably
won't be a corporation I mean it's you
know what's cool about what we're
working on is it's really hard and
interesting which means because of the
hard problem and there's like financial
incentive you get to work with a bunch
of other really smart people which is
cool but you know like have any wake up
to an alarm every day
and like B there's a huge cost like
coordination with a bunch of other
people hmm
like everyone has to be awake every at
the same time it's just like do I want
to do that I don't know goes real well
but the thing is it's not like the alarm
is like kind of it I know a big thing
yeah but it's so hard to get into like a
creative mode or you can like you know
like I forget takes like hours to get to
the point where you can like hmm be like
productive creatively and so then any
sort of like routine and scheduling can
just really disrupt that like if the
muse is speaking you want to be able to
like write down yeah he's sane and be
like available to that which one you're
like coordinating like huge chunks of
your day around other people's time it
can be difficult so but then on the
other hand like the idea of like just
you know solo you know writing all the
time that seems kind of lonely so I
don't know it's a tough yeah I think it
cuts both ways but I know so many people
that are like I'll dude if I just like
quit this job
then I can do my thing and then the
greater job yeah it's hard it's hard
really hard they're like do something
yeah I mean you got to be super
disciplined either way yeah that's it
I'm sure there's someone who's like just
randomly like mom there's a movie idea
and it immediately becomes super
successful but most people not so much
so so this other essay where you talk
about technological determinism the
emperor has no clothes there is no Santa
Claus and nothing is rocket science this
was a lecture at Cal yeah right and I
found it really interesting because it
kind of ends up dovetailing with a lot
of the ideas that you talk about in the
context of like okay maybe in a future
we will not have to work but as it
currently stands I'm working you're
working you're looking for jobs whatever
this is a lecture to call it undergrad
yeah college kids right in a class where
like all the other lectures are by
business people about what like starting
companies and stuff okay yeah and I
thought you started it out in like in a
very honest way where you say I wasn't
there but I just read the these this
like transcript right yeah yeah you say
I want to preface this talk by warning
you that it's quite possible your
interpret you'll you will interpret much
of this talk as cynicism it's not my
intention to be cynical of my goal is to
treat you with respect
by speaking to you honestly without any
grand illusions and then you go off
write a paragraph that jumped out to me
is you said none of the companies trying
to convince you to work for them will
mention technological determinism they
will confirm your what your parents and
teachers told you that your work and
contribution will be totally unique and
significant yeah that's a that's mean
that's a it's kind of a shitty thing to
hear as a college student I think I
remember like a similar thing I heard
from my college professor like I was
having coffee with right after I
graduated she said to me like I remember
I was like about your age when I
realized that I didn't have time in life
to do all the things I wanted to do and
I was like I like the idea of like you
know telling somebody something honest
like that when they're younger but the I
don't know but the kind of thing I was
getting at was a lot of this was I've
had a ton of fun working on hard
problems with smart people but I think I
see a lot of companies and like I'll go
visit college campuses a lot to do
recruiting and kind of look at like I'll
look at other companies like engineering
blogs and just like or like I'll hear
no advertisements on like a podcast by
some engineering company and when I
graduated from college and I went to
like Penn where you know Wharton is a
big part of the culture there and so
it's like a very it's basically a
vocational school hmm
and that infects the entire rest of you
know every other program at Penn it's
like everybody's very focused on your
like gen ed business class you have to
take know I mean but it's just the vibe
of Penn it's like my you and it's like
yeah it's like everybody's like you know
what internship am I getting or whatever
and when I graduated from school I don't
know 2005 pretty much everyone that did
a good job in high school get into a
good school the next like step then they
were told to do was to go get a job on
Wall Street at an investment bank or at
a consulting company like a top for a
consulting company huh and that was just
like the track and then you kind of like
get married and have kids and you have a
stable life now I think that those type
of people who followed the track that
was put in front of them go to get jobs
here in Silicon Valley technology
corporations but and I think that's fine
like if your goal is like if with what
you value is providing sustenance or
like you know a stable home environment
for like kids or for other people that
depend on you it's probably a great way
to do that but my problem with the way
that Silicon Valley does it is they
they've always had this like wall street
is the bad guys they're all about making
money Silicon Valley's about you know
building the future and you know like
achieving like the American Dream and
like just being the doing no evil and
it's really like
I don't know like maybe some people get
that out of it but I have a problem with
you like selling that to other people
and telling them that you're gonna be
their source of meaning and you're gonna
enable them to like be impactful in the
world I kind of like like there's a
certain honesty to like the Wall Street
it's like come here work hard make a lot
of money yeah
like okay like that's the deal and these
technology companies don't really I
meant like that and I just like there's
a lot of great companies do and the
building things that like are making the
world better in a lot of ways but I just
think they oversell this feel good about
yourself thing right when they probably
don't even have to yeah yeah I don't
know I like on one hand I do think that
technology usually is a good thing and
like many of these companies are working
on great stuff and they're also giving
jobs to people that are you know great
solid income yeah and I have no beef
with someone it's like hey I'm just
gonna go work at whatever X company make
this money you know I'm like providing
for our family your parents or yeah or
or just you know myself
which is fine and then like the thing
that's been kind of working me lately is
like financial independence being used
as this like metagame that gets like
kind of thrown into the mix with young
people many of whom don't really have to
earn $300,000 a year
like they come maybe they come from a
family whatever it looked like they can
support them and and it just makes me
sad because I'm like oh you're kind of
getting played with this game and
because you're like by default this game
is like a multi-year game that will
encompass like your 20s you might not
ever do anything yeah and that makes me
sad but yeah yeah you know there's a lot
of time after your 20s to the you say no
totally but I just like speaking
obviously people do things over the
course of their entire lives but I look
around at my friends and like yeah you
have kids and it's very easy and
don't have kids so it's hard for me to
say but like it's very easy it seems to
make that your whole thing yeah but you
I guess also fine yeah I mean that's a
and I just I I think it's a fine
decision if people kind of go into it
with open eyes and like fully understand
it I feel like I just feel like there's
like a little bit too much marketing of
it in a certain direction that makes me
uncomfortable yeah hmm you said at a
point I mean you're quoting some of the
advertisements so you like the words
were craft built for everyone do you
think I'm just laughing do the most
meaningful work of your career like
maybe but the line that jumped out
afterwards that I really liked is when
you said I recognize that the meditative
aspect of craft is an excellent way to
cope with meaninglessness yeah which
yeah yeah I mean that's a it is a it's
very meditative to it like one of the
things that's awesome about writing
software you can just like go into this
you know stage where you're just you you
spend 10 hours and you're like whoa that
was so fun it's like playing a video
game right or I mean I think I'm not
like a great drawer but like I've done
some drawing like when you're like just
you know drawing that cup of water right
there and like looking at all the
different like shadows and contours and
just focused on that you kind of throw
out all this verbal analytical mmm parts
of your brain and that is probably the
type of stuff that leads you to
existential despair it can be nice to
escape that for a while and I think like
craft has that sort of you know like
cooking is like that or you know writing
software is like that working with your
hands I think is like that they're doing
excel I think like there's a lot of
things that are like that we can can
like just focus in go into that you know
all this all the
everything else dims and you're just
like in the zone yeah and it's a good
escape from a lot of other things I
think it's also a helpful way to well
it's an easy way to critique other
people without getting to the core of
the thing it's uh I used to do it I mean
I still do it so one of my by saying
like I'm a craftsman well I mean you
could treat get one who's not a
craftsman
well that's one that I've definitely
heard another one is just critiquing
someone else's style without getting to
the core of the thing yeah
another one is saying like oh you didn't
do this well and I would have done it
really well without recognizing that you
didn't you didn't do it at all and this
person is accomplishing stuff yeah and I
think that is not it's not healthy but
then on the other hand some people clear
like all these things are dichotomies
right yeah yeah is just tough there's a
lot of garbage out there but there's a
lot of people trying their best
I don't know yeah I mean at some point
in one of the essays you mentioned like
it's possible that like VR would be a
suitable life for out four people maybe
not for you right now but at some point
who knows yeah I mean my R is pretty
good right now I like to say so yeah why
is the art better than the VR I don't
know that seems kind of random it's all
just by the time you're conscious of it
it's all information anyway so
theoretically you could have a VR that
yeah who's just as good as reality oh
yeah I mean VR plus some kind of like
chemical combination I could absolutely
see them better than real life yeah for
for almost everyone yeah it's not a rule
I could like be a professional
basketball player in PR never gonna
happen
you can be good yeah I mean it so if you
could somehow slip into that like really
feel like you're LeBron James yeah I've
never dumped a basketball in my entire
life I've probably be pretty sick it
would be awesome like I love in a
stadium with 50,000 people like cheering
you on
I I could be down with that that sounds
awesome yeah but again you're left with
this thing is like okay
like after I've consumed every level of
the VR game yeah
maybe maybe it's just life there's this
good Alan Watts thing I heard where he
was talking about being omnipotent and
living forever he was like you know you
would an omniscient and he was like yeah
you you know you would be cool for a
while but then you probably get bored
and you start doing these simulations
where you're like okay like I'm gonna
make this game where I like limit my
omnipotence in some way and you know
just it'll make it a little bit more fun
and then you kind of get bored of that
game you realize like well like I always
know that at the after the game is over
I'm omnipotent and omniscient and I went
forever
and so it's like lowers the stakes a
little bit and so you like then you
start taking away the fact that you know
it's a game I think he like returned to
this state of the struggle of limited
finite life it was just like he kind of
like got there from well of course
that's what you do if you live forever
and where I'm not doing right exactly
this it traps you I mean do you uh do
you ever lucid dream mmm not really
I have the thing where I become
conscious but can't move when right
before you wake up which I don't like ya
know I wish I loose it dreams instead I
haven't had your experience but I've
definitely lucid dreams quite a bit and
my problem is exactly what you're
describing usually what happens is
something's happening and then I predict
what will happen in the dream and that
it happens and then it just happens over
and over and over again until you
realize you're in complete control of
the dream and then you wake up yeah and
that's yeah you I rapidly ruined the
entire thing yes and you could you just
so people understand we did a podcast
with them with Tim urban wait but why
hmm
well he's cool yeah and he talks about
this technological determinism as the
human Colossus it's basically the same
concept yeah there's like this ball is
rolling this product will be made you
even say if venmo if not been mo
something else yeah it would have
happened for sure in that same space yes
how do you define technological
determinism yeah I mean the way I talk
about it in that talk was like a little
bit I was talking more about corollary
like technological determinism I think
is just the society is a product of
technology or something but the kind of
thing I think about a lot as a corollary
of that is that kind of I think like
evolution is like this and like
technology is like this where things
that are efficient and productive will
eventually be created out of necessity
because you know they make life more
successful but if you kind of like
follow that to attend you get into this
place where it's like okay well like if
everything useful will necessarily be
invented by somebody out of need like
like why should I work on anything right
like if any any possible useful thing I
could come up with somebody else is
gonna come up with because it's useful
so like why do it's not that unique or
interesting like so maybe I just do like
all the crazy useless stuff in order to
try to rescue my free will basically no
the problem with that is if everybody
thought that nothing useful right would
ever get done so it's kind of like
presupposes that it's a like you know
only a few people realize that I guess
but I don't know that's kind of how I
think about technological determinism is
idea like yeah useful stuff will be
built technology is moving forward at
this pace it's kind of like an
unstoppable force yeah and as much as
like people you know yearn for the
good old days or the you know Portland
life of you know making your own cottage
cheese or whatever you're not gonna
somebody's gonna keep technology moving
forward so it's tough to ya against it
and you use a JFK's moral argument yeah
that that JFK's speech from it was a he
gave this talk at Rice talking about the
space program and he was talking about
why quiet like why are we going to space
cost a ton of money yeah he says some
awesome stuff in there one he's like why
does Rice play Texas and he was like
comparing the space race to a football
game which i think is hilarious like I
had to step back because that was the
one that I was like I don't know like
college football rankings well enough
and I was like oh it's because Texas is
amazing in Rice it's like okay right
that's the argument well I just think
it's why do I need is it one college
play another college at all like why
does that even like why is there a
football game right because it's fun and
like competition is interesting until
like that's kind of like one angle of it
which is like I think really probably
the better argument we're like maybe the
more sorry that maybe like the more
truthful argument he then gives us other
argument which is if we don't do this
space exploration thing somebody else
will and right now that somebody else is
Russia and we don't know their motives
and you know space technology like all
other technology it has no morals of its
own and so it's sort of like up to the
good people or the more moral people who
like if you're in the u.s. that's you
presumably if you're JFK's audience it's
up to the good people to like build the
powerful technology first so that they
can fight back against the bad people
who also will eventually build that
technology I think that was like it just
really
interesting argument you can justify
like a lot of things without argument
and like who's to say that once you
build the technology what you'll use it
for but that was a pretty compelling
argument I thought I mean it's the same
one that open AI is using right now yeah
and most a AI researchers yeah so which
is I mean at some point we should talk
about where you're currently working on
yeah right so yeah sue it
so what's thin is within AI sphere yeah
weird so we'd like to call AAA AI
artificial artificial intelligence when
we started the company there was like
all this so Finn it's a personal
assistant service and so you can like
email us text us tell us whatever send
this work like you would send an
executive assistant and when we started
there was like all this excitement about
like Alexa and Google home and all these
pure software AI natural language
processing things which have very good
speech-to-text kind of natural language
processing and are pretty good at
understanding like most sentences that
you would say to them but they're not
really capable of being your full-time
assistant um and so our thought was well
you know these people are saying like
this is gonna be you know like the AI
from 2001 Space Odyssey or like Jarvis
from Ironman like it's no were even
close to that but we want those things
so why don't we like try to build that
today and hack it by having a system
where you you interact with it just like
that mm-hmm but instead of trying to
build it with pure software which if
Google can't do obviously like it's not
possible we'll just have a team of
people on the backend but do it a little
bit more like uber where it's a network
of people providing the service they're
enabled by technology like uber not
gonna be possible without GPS so there
are certain like technological
improvements you can take advantage of
to like enable this distributed
workforce to provided new kind of
service it wasn't really possible in the
and we thought it'd be cool to do that
for personal assistance type stuff and
just take all these sort of mundane
digital chores that you don't want to do
yourself but that you're probably doing
right now because there's like okay
tools to do them and because there's
like okay tools to do them not many
people have assistants anymore and so
they're doing them themselves but it's
really like not an efficient use of your
time for instance you're some a good
Julia or whatever to be like scheduling
five hours of meetings every week right
like and like you know I guess like
venture capitalist they you know would
typically have somebody's scheduling
their meetings but there's a lot of
other people where they don't have an
assistant and they're doing stuff like
that at work or maybe they're just doing
stuff at home like you know dealing with
service providers and Comcast and like a
plumber and if you're spending three
hours of doing that a week which is like
for a lot people they probably are and
you have kids that's like three hours
that you're not spending with their kids
and if you ask somebody like which one
would you rather do go help your kid
with their homework or like play with
them for three hours or be figuring out
something with your health insurance
like clearly people are gonna choose
spend time with their kids the sort of
historical problem is you can't really
get an assistant for three hours per
week it's it's pretty tricky to figure
out how yeah I mean there are people
that tell you you can do that it's
pretty hard to do that to get somebody
good you typically have to buy in chunks
of 40 hours per week or just do like
tons of work to figure out like vet
somebody find people on up work or
whatever it is like some remote VA and
then if that person disappears you have
to do the whole thing again they're just
like huge amount of cost involved in
like trying to piecemeal it together so
we thought like okay like why don't we
kind of like do all that work to like
find good people train them build it so
it's like a kind of like consistent
reliable experience remember all the
sort of like nuances and preferences
about you so that when turnover and
nutrition does happen you're shielded
from that
and like the entity like remembers your
preferences around dentist appointments
or whatever right you don't want to have
to tell you know if you if you're hiring
a new assistant every year because
they're turning over it's not really
useful to have a that person to your
dentist thing because you only do that
once a year and you have to like retrain
them on the entire thing every time so
we've kind of taken some a group of
people that we have trained them give
them tools for collaboration knowledge
sharing workflow management process
management and built this system we're
like everything that any one of them
learns about you or about the world like
how to book Hamilton tickets or like how
to do one medical writer like encode
that in our system and we can actually
be a lot more efficient that then a
single person on their own could be and
we can give it to you in a much more
incremental way we don't have to buy in
blocks of 40 hours got it and so there
are many questions around Wolfen so Ryan
Hoover from producthunt
yeah asks when if ever wolf in task
completion be 100% a high driven yeah I
mean what if the day that happens nobody
has to work anymore right because if
Finn is a black box open-ended system
yeah like we will do any work that you
send us right so the day that Finn can
do all work no human has to work again
and then we're all go to the beach and
drink pina coladas and we're at the
beginning beginning of the podcast yeah
yeah that'll be great
so our sort of bet is while there is any
human work to be done let's build the
system that is the best at doing human
work and we'll use software to give our
humans leverage and hopefully make them
far more productive than somebody who's
not part of our network or doesn't have
access to it like our tools and
knowledge base and you know for the
decades to come while humans still have
to work we want to be the best place to
do all that work are all these people in
the bay or they all
no no there most of our people over at
now are in Phoenix okay yeah what's been
the the hardest part and the biggest
difference between starting fen first
dyma I mean booth then though it was
always really difficult to raise money
because it was a very expensive business
to run
and it had to be like a huge like event
Mo's just now starting to like start to
monetize yeah with and the the method
for that is to enable all these
consumers to pay businesses because mi
doesn't make money when you pay your
friends back and so that was like a very
very like long-term bet on a certain way
to make money and because we were never
making any money and had to deal with
all these like SEC laws and things like
that it was always like very difficult
to raise money and we had to like use
money for all these things that were not
really like making the product better so
that was like a kind of thing that made
that mo hard I know so it was like the
first kind of like company of any size
that I worked on so yeah first time
managing people so we lots of challenges
like that
with Finn on the other hand I like have
a little bit more experience managing
people so that part like is somewhat
easier or you know at least I have like
some experience and knowledge of doing
it in the past and we have a business
model we're both like kind of like
previous entrepreneurs and have like
social capital so that made it a little
bit easier to raise money and then the
hard the hardest thing about Finn is
just complexity it's like the exact
opposite of any of like the perfect YC
company where's like the YC company you
pick one or like any you know like a
Silicon Valley company you pick like one
small thing
you get really good at doing that thing
you get by doing tons and tons of reps
on it and then if you get a bunch of
people using that then maybe you kind of
like expand outward and like add on like
another little thing and then get really
good at that with Finn we're competing
with
a full-time human assistant and a
full-time human assistant we'll just do
whatever you ask them it's like you hire
a human assistant and he's like hey can
you help me find the time to meet with
Sam next week and book me flights to
Phoenix yeah and then the person says
like well I don't book flight so you're
gonna have to do that yourself but I'll
schedule the meeting like that if we'd
built that we just wouldn't be
competitive with a human assistant so we
kind of took in to this we have to be
able to do anything which is really hard
one it's just hard to like kind of mark
it and like explain to people what we do
because it's like it's not like we do
one thing we just see whatever the other
thing is it's really hard to understand
the second thing it's really hard to
just build tools that do anything that
are like both very general and also like
pretty productive and easy for people
who learn so this it's hard to build the
tools for our team that's doing all work
and then probably one of the most
challenging things is measurement and we
spend a huge amount of time on
measurement trying to understand things
like okay who who's doing a good job on
our team and who's not who needs help
where do they need help who's good at
which specific type of tasks where is
all the time going why is this thing you
know this one type of task greater
variance and a larger type of task in
terms of like how long it typically
takes somebody our team to do it how do
we categorize like different groups of
customers and understand like what they
would want like what they would demand
we have to also predict for any given
week of the year for any given day of
the week for any given hour of the day
how much customer demand is there going
to be because we're like stocking labor
basically and if we're under supply then
people have to wait too long for work to
get done for oversupply then we're just
like burning money yep
and then the other thing that's really
hard to it the measurement is just hard
because it's a black box system and so
we have
a heterogeneous set of people doing the
work who have very different tenures
which is a lot a big thing that like
affects how well they do their work
different different innate skill sets
and then a very heterogeneous set of
customers and a very heterogeneous set
of types of tasks that we do and so it
can be really hard to like say we
released a new thing last week is it
making the system better or worse to try
to find an apples-to-apples trendline
where you can say like okay like here is
the impact of that thing you have to
slice on so many dimensions to try to
get to a data set they can tell you if
any of the work that you did was
actually good or bad so it's just really
complicated it feels like I'm like
trying Leena to do measurement in like
macroeconomics or they're just like a
billion different dimensions and you're
like constantly like oh well we have
like a normalize for this and normalize
for that
how much is usage correlated with what
you mark it that fin can do I think
today your demand for fin is much more
function of you than of our marketing so
to get you to realize that it's more a
matter of just kind of making sure you
know that the basics of the system it's
helpful like talk to you about it
because it's like very difficult to put
in friendly and like it's really helpful
like ask questions about like what your
needs are and then basically we just
tell you like we can do all this thing
yeah but we can't like know a priori
what your needs are and then like put
those on the page for you right so
there's a certain sense we're like
talking to you for a little bit helps us
like realize your full potential as a
customer but say you're the type of
person that needs five hours of help per
week we're not gonna invent another like
five hours of work that we can do for
you like so it's a little bit different
than like a media business
in that sense where we could probably
come up with another five hours of like
TV that you would be entertained by even
if you were only currently spending five
hours already
yeah week but it's not like as soon as
you say Finn will book flights for you
everyone uses Finn to book flights well
the people that need a flight booked but
we're not gonna convince somebody that
doesn't need a flight to book a flight
right of course so it's it's very much a
function of like each individual
customer like what they'll find
gosh you're not so do you do you ever
have a moment when you talked about your
Lucas venmo hats do you ever have a
moment where you're like I want to do
this again undo the same thing I want to
do it for fun and like get these ads
everywhere I don't like to do like the
you know do a read you like that I mean
had the Lucas that word really these
really Subway's had that we did yeah for
venmo in New York that was really fun to
be I don't think we would do something
like that
because that was a the the market for
that was a little bit different where
it's like every person could use venmo
you know when that when those ads went
up in New York with Finn it's like it's
not a product for every person right now
the thing I liked about Lucas was that
it was not really it was like in the
place where you would see an ad but it
wasn't actually really an ad it was more
of like a non sequitur it's like
confusing stickers all over the stuff
way yeah so I like the idea and I've
done this like with stuff on my website
where like you know like my about me is
like not really in about me it's like
partly fictional and like really long
and like just not it's you looking like
a place where you're expecting to see
one thing yeah and then you see
something that doesn't really belong
there but your conversion rates bro yeah
but I like that and so it there's
something about that and thinking about
okay what would that be for a Finn
mm-hmm
you know could be like you know being
showing up at some conference and like
doing some crazy [ __ ] that was like not
what we were supposed to be there to do
I think that would be fun
but I'm sure would be different than
like what we what worked for them oh we
do for fun mm-hmm so Spencer Clark asked
how did you and your co-founder decide
to sell venmo
or why well the one it was the options
were shut down venmo
forever or sell it so that was like a
pretty easy decision the reasons why I
mean what's probably more interesting is
to talk about like why was Braintree a
good match
four of em oh so one obviously like Bill
Reddy who was the CEO of Braintree only
person that kind of like got it and was
willing to like fund the vision of them
though and like build up this consumer
base for the sake of having a bunch of
people who were wired up and comfortable
using payments on their phone so that
they could eventually pay businesses
he was particularly I think amenable to
them though because Braintree had it was
brain trees in our company similar
stripe where they have they do credit
card processing for all these different
businesses and the margins on credit
card processing are really thin mm-hmm
for some of the green to you're like
stripe but for PayPal they're actually
awesome because PayPal was basically
doing a ton of transactions that come
from bank accounts and then charging a
credit card processing face instead of
making like five basis points PayPal is
making like 2% or something so it really
like gives you many many more multiples
on your margins if you're in that
payment processing business and so what
Bill saw was like okay like venmo could
help
Braintree go from this like very very
very thin margin mythos to like what's
still pretty thin margins but like any
standard but like still many multiples
on what they had so that was kind of why
he thought it was a good fit and the
team's kind of meshed well and they were
well capitalized and had like a source
of revenue and could kind of like
balance out all this venmo that was
basically just dumping into user
acquisition and wiring up people's bank
accounts with the
hopes that one day we could somehow
convince merchants to accept Rosa for
mana so it just made a lot of sense one
for ven mode to be part of Braintree
because it was like this sort of like
matching halves and then the same thing
when PayPal acquired Braintree I think
PayPal was one of the few people that
could like understand the value of Mo
because it's like basically the same
exact playbook as PayPal understand like
the long-term investment it takes I mean
I'm sure it's it's probably been over
like a billion dollar investment now to
like wire up all these bank accounts and
subsidize all the period for your
transactions with the hopes of someday
turning on payments to the merchant
network which is now finally happening
and my guess is will probably work out
pretty well for PayPal but like it you
would be very difficult I think for a
private financier to kind of accept the
billion dollar dream question yeah so it
just made made sense yeah
how long ago was that I think 2013 as
well yeah yeah the last thing I want to
talk about was that Charlie Kaufman
speech man that's so dared everyone
anybody was like those things should go
you should link to that speech Charlie
Kaufman - cool I'd never heard him speak
before I think that's like one of the
only times he did that oh okay yeah yeah
that was great did you transcribe that
on your own just like no I I think I
found either the YouTube transcription
and cleaned up or it might have been on
BAFTAs website somewhere okay but I kind
of pasted the transcripts on my side
because I want to like add emphasis in
certain areas because it's long I
thought it might be helpful to have like
some highlights in there but yeah I love
them if you want like sleazoid beaches
or like give people some context but
it's so Charlie Kaufman's a screenwriter
Being John Malkovich
many other movies yeah and that
basically the set up is talking about I
mean I can just I can pull it out right
here so she talks for a while and then
he goes into this moment of self
reflection on the talk to the audience
about his own talk where he says what
I'm trying to express what I'd like to
express is the notion that by being
honest thoughtful and aware of the
existence of other living beings a
change can begin to happen and how we
think of ourselves in the world in and
ourselves in the world so it was awesome
yeah I mean there's so much in there
that's okay it's really one of the best
things I've come across in many years
it's really inspiring he talks a lot
about sort of his motives what he's
trying to do in film and just making
things and I think he kind of in that it
gives context for a lot of stuff he's
seen his films where he's reacting to
this um mechanization of human relations
the kind of alienated us from each other
and prevent authentic communication and
he points to that in a lot of problems
that he sees in film with people just
like mechanizing and putting out more of
the same [ __ ] that's just copying
something else in that DNA they knew but
I think in a lot of the work he does you
can see he sees that also in our like
daily interactions with other people or
like in our relationships with even like
family and friends and stuff it's very
easy to just fall into a routine and
like just saying the thing that is
automatic and he gives this part there's
this part in that speech where he talks
about he's running in his neighborhood
and he passes this guy running
and the guy and he's uh he's running
down the hill on this guy who's running
up a hill and the guy's like well sure
it's all it's all downhill that way and
he laughs and he's like ah that was a
good and then he passes the guy again
same spot and got it same exact thing
says hey he's like oh that's kind of
interesting I guess maybe like he'd
forgot he said to me
another it happens in another time same
spot
he's like I guess he just says that
every time he sees somebody here he like
wasn't really even paying attention to
me and then he passes him like and he
like Charlie Kaufman's going up hill and
the other guy's going down hill but he
still says sure it's all down to that
way it's like it has no context they're
like recognition or acknowledgement of
like the state of the actual world it's
just this automatic thing to say and I
think I don't know he points it out in
it can happen to our work and couldn't
happen to our relationships with other
people and I know I found that really
poignant it was so great and it
especially in the context of a type of
work that I think most people regard as
very creative yeah he's like he goes
into craft in the same way that you talk
about it he's like oh I don't think he
says the name of the movie but he's like
I saw the Strahler for this movie that's
gonna come out is beautiful I'm sure
it's gonna be perfectly done yeah but
it's just gonna be totally mediocre yeah
not really accomplish anything yeah
and so yeah I think like the first of
all thanks for posting and I had I had
not seen it before but also I was just
curious about like how you're you're
trying to personally apply this idea cuz
it's obvious based on all your
highlights that you cared about it a lot
yeah I really I really feel like there's
a lot of important stuff in there but I
just I don't like the idea this is a
little bit gifts I think I was saying
that Berkeley was there's a track that
you know has been laid out for everybody
and just like the certain way of doing
things like you can it's very easy to
just like do the automatic
next thing without thinking about it and
then wake up 50 years later and realize
you haven't thought for yourself at all
not to say that it's necessarily bad -
I'm probably like a little bit more
generous on listen Charlie Kaufman would
be I don't think it's just really bad to
like do something that other people are
doing or like that have been done before
if you decide that that is like the
thing that you want to spend time doing
or that's gonna like facilitate some
other thing that you want to do what's
tragic to me is that there's a lot of
people who don't even like understand
that they're in this automatic mode and
just like following the next thing and
like copying the thing that somebody
else did or somebody doing nothing that
somebody told them to do
and the idea of like someone that like
that you know waking up 50 years later
at me like well I didn't want to do any
of that or just never realizing having
that thought at all I was just sad so I
try to spend a lot of time thinking
about like okay like how do I be
intentional like am i doing the thing
that I want to do is it gonna be like
different in some way and something up
because I do like the of trying to do
something differently than the way other
people would do it so I think about that
a lot but it's kind of a radical and
like you can you can spend a lot of time
thinking about that and realize that
it's pretty hard to do and maybe not
possible yeah yeah and you can fall into
a new kind of trap which is competitive
mindfulness yes I find so funny
yes so I can meditate longer than you
can yeah all right dude so if someone
wants to talk to you online or try out
Finn what should they do so try out Finn
we have a code for E and somebody asks
like one spin gonna be free cuz I could
be free but you get $100 credit if you
sign up at Finn calm /yc
so you could just try that out there and
then if you want to find me online
Cortina with a K on Twitter or Kourt
em I see is where I post on my reading
awesome
thanks man thank you
you